the prosecutor in the kyle rittenhouse
case
is the charlie kelly of prosecutors it
is like the worst episode of always
sunny ever
the prosecutor the the more that his
arguments fail the more that the judge
loses patience with him
the the more desperate and outlandish he
seems to get i am waiting for this
prosecutor to bring up bird law as one
might do in an episode if it's always
sunny
one of the final
closing arguments that the prosecutor
made is that
if you
arm yourself if you exercise your second
amendment right to keep and bear arms
you
paradoxically
lose the right to self-defense
he brought his ar-15
that's why he's got to come up with this
cockamamie theory that joseph rosenbaum
was not only going to take the gun
but take it and then turn it on the
defendant and the defendant actually
told you
that he thought joseph rosenbaum was
going to take that gun and not only kill
him but kill other people which is
really ironic considering the defendant
is the one who killed people in this
case and the only one
but
putting that aside
they have to convince you that joseph
rosenbaum was going to take that gun and
use it on the defendant because they
know
you can't claim self-defense
against an unarmed man like this
you lose the right to self-defense when
you're the one who brought the gun when
you're the one creating the damn danger
so that is simply not true
that that is completely that has no
basis in the law or in history or in
common sense you can't lose your right
to self-defense if you are defending
yourself if you're arming yourself to
defend yourself
then you don't have a right to
self-defense
and furthermore
if if the prosecutor's claim is that
kyle rittenhouse had no reason to
believe that the
the
joseph rosenbaum this dead child rapist
he was obviously wasn't dead at the time
but he was a child rapist at the time
and what he did do at the time is
threatened to kill kyle rittenhouse so
the prosecutor's saying this is a
cockamamie crazy theory that he pulled
out of thin air that he was afraid that
joseph rosenbaum was going to kill him
he literally threatened to do that he
actually said i am going to kill you
guys if i see you out tonight
and then he tried to
and then he got killed for his trouble
that's what happens that's called
self-defense
then
as if the prosecutor had not embarrassed
himself enough
he decided to reenact the scene he
thought okay look my my
rhetorical skills
are
pretty subpar but maybe if i pantomime
what happened if i act it out maybe then
i will be able to convince the jury that
kyle rittenhouse's obvious self-defense
was not justified so this maniac picks
up an ar-15 and just starts swinging it
around the courtroom
the defendant comes running in and drops
the fire extinguisher on the ground like
and then this his left hand to the gun
and points
this is what we see in the video
him putting the fire extinguisher on the
ground and then raising the gun whoa
john armand object he's facing the wrong
direction
that's an argument okay
whoa buddy chill out
chill out with the ar-15 you lunatic
look i'm not saying that i have the most
intense rigorous firearms training that
i am some expert on guns i'm not i have
some firearms training i've fired a gun
on a number of occasions and i've
had people show me how to do it and
what's the first thing they tell you not
to do what's the very first thing
if you've ever touched a gun in your
life the first thing they tell you not
to do don't point it at people actually
there are two first things you're gonna
hear don't point it at people and don't
put your finger on the trigger unless
you are ready to kill whatever is in
front of the barrel of that gun and what
does this schmuck do he picks up a
freaking ar-15 puts his finger on the
trigger and starts swinging it around
the courtroom he should be disbarred for
this
that's not an exaggeration
if i were at a gun range if i were in a
gun store and i behaved like this i
would be kicked out of that store in two
seconds
much less a court of law
but the gun's not loaded okay first of
all
if you've been paying attention to the
news over the past few weeks you'll know
that sometimes people think guns aren't
loaded when they actually are
if the set of alec baldwin's movie had
paid a little more attention to gun
safety the cinematographer would still
be alive
but two
it just shows the
unseriousness
of this prosecution
this guy
this prosecutor who's representing the
state
is trying to make claims about kyle
rittenhouse's use of a gun and his use
of his right to self-defense without
knowing even the most basic things about
guns or the right to self-defense
he was wrong on the law and he's wrong
on the gun and he has absolutely no idea
what he's talking about and the only
thing that he can hope for in this case
is that the culture of scapegoating kyle
rittenhouse the culture of saying right
wing bad left-wing good
white guy bad other all the victims not
victims all of the people who were
killed
by kyle rittenhouse and self-defense in
this case were white too so the race
isn't a huge issue here but is it a blm
protest so you know blm
rioter is good
anti-blm
protesters bad right they're just
counting on this media narrative
and the pressure of the president and
the pressure of blm and the threats that
are coming in from the left to try to
sway the jury
because on the facts of the case on the
logic of the case
the prosecution doesn't have
anything
you you you hold on hold on
thank you for stopping by i'm glad you
watched that clip
if you wouldn't mind ring that bell
subscribe you will get notifications and
if our overlords on the big tech
platforms don't give you notifications i
would strongly recommend you head on
over to apple podcasts spotify stitcher
google play wherever you get your audio
podcast subscribe to the michael knowles
show maybe leave a five-star review if
you want to make me feel good
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you